Hello Freak bitches.
What is the argument about the Sphinx?
The enclosure,
this banks and doctor Robert Schoch from Boston University who's a geologist.
What was his conclusion?
What shock is saying is that the Sphinx and the trench out of which the Sphinx
is cut a bas,
the unmistakable evidence of precipitation induced weathering,
weathering caused by exposure to a substantial period of heavy rainfall.
And that is particularly pointed out in the vertical fissures in the trench.
They see the Sphinx itself has been subject to so much restoration over so many
years that is difficult for people to even see the core body of the Sphinx
today.
Uh,
but it's these,
you can see the vertical fissures even down at the back of there.
That is,
that is what shock counts as rainfall,
precipitation induced weathering,
heavy rainfall,
which is selectively removing the softer layers and leaving the harder layers in
place.
And the problem is we don't have that rainfall in Giza in Egypt four and a half
thousand years ago.
You have to go back much earlier to get that rainfall as the suggestion.
So that's the suggestion by Robert Schoch independently.
Yes.
If your conclusion is a delay independently.
Yeah,
shock disagrees with me on many things as,
as a matter of fact.
Uh,
and,
and I disagree with him on many things,
but I think he's on the money on this.
So that alone would set back at least that one.
I mean it's pretty much established that the Great Pyramid of Giza was
constructed about 2,500 BC.
Right.
Is absolutely no doubt that a huge project went on at Giza around 2,500.
So you are getting involved appear not that the whole thing was that much older
was that parts of it seem to have been from an earlier civilization or at least
that civilization far,
far earlier than I was.
I would say that the ground plan,
what we have at Giza,
the basic layout of the site was established in what the ancient Egyptians
called Zep Tepi the first time.
Uh,
astronomically.
And geologically I and my colleagues suggest that the first time can be dated to
the period of about 12 and a half to 13,000 years ago.
That,
that that was when the site was laid out.
Cause there's intriguing astronomical alignments of the Great Pyramids to the
belt of Orion.
I know ed crop has a completely opposite view on this and have the greatest
things to the constellation of Leo rising due East housing,
the sun on the equinox,
the astrological age of Leo.
Again,
I have slides I can align with the geological evidence that Robert Schoch
[inaudible] with the geological evidence,
years or age of Leo pretty much exactly spans the younger dryas as matter of
fact.
And so the only argument against that at the time was that there were no other
structures like that from 12,000 years.
Correct.
And then crop said that the,
that the Orion correlation wasn't real.
Uh,
because it was upside down.
I'm a do you want to get into that now?
Well,
the first,
um,
that's not the only argument.
It's that,
okay.
If the Sphinx is built or the layout for the whole thing is built in,
uh,
you know,
say 10,
11,000 years ago and then the,
and then the pyramids are built,
you know,
2,500 BC w w what happened in between where all the people,
the trash,
the places where they lived?
Well,
there's a bunch different styles of
construction but not dated in between.
I would propose Michael,
something like a monastery,
which has a relatively small archeological footprint is on the side.
I mean the idea of information,
knowledge and traditions lasting for thousands of years within a religious
system shouldn't be too absurd to us.
I mean Judaism is,
is,
is dealing with ideas that are already best part of 4,000 years old if we go
back to or have the child is and so on and so forth.
So that's all I'm suggesting really that,
that the idea is preserved,
maintained that the,
the survivors,
the survey on the site,
but on something like a monastery,
which is,
which has got a very small archeological footprint,
it is not high.
Perhaps again,
one can only speculate and I think there's a lot of speculation on the
archeological side to one can only speculate perhaps having gone through a
cataclysm,
perhaps they felt to blame for this wrongly or rightly.
I mean there are many,
many traditions in which humanity's behavior is implicated in the cataclysm that
takes place and perhaps they didn't want to switch civilization on completely
right there.
Perhaps they perhaps they waited pass down the knowledge through initiates
enough was there to create a mystery because it's undoubtedly a mystery that the
construction of the Great Pyramids,
the first huge pyramids in Egypt proceeded only really by the Xhosa pyramid at
Saqqara.
The construction of the Great Pyramids is vastly superior to the construction of
the Pyramids of the fifth and sixth dynasty that follow it.
And that's a little bit counter intuitive that we have this collapse in skills.
One would have expected it to get better.
So it sounds like the work on the pyramids started already with a level of
knowledge in hand.
Yes.
But okay,
so here's,
here's how I would think about that.
There's a lot of perhaps seen and maybe because yes.
Well,
so you have a bunch of Egyptologists and archeologists who have been working on
this site for centuries.
This is one of the most ancient mysteries and so on and so say,
let's say there's like 20 lines of evidence that point to build roughly around
this time period here,
and then you come on and say,
okay,
but there's this one anomaly of the rain thing that there was only rain at this
time.
Now there's a huge gap.
You have one anomaly or line of evidence here,
and like 20 here we're talking about different structures,
so there's not a lot of evidence of points of the Sphinx being from a particular
time period.
Well,
he's saying like 12,000 right?
I'm saying the rainfall evidence suggests that by other evidence that alignment,
it's alignment with the Constellation of Leo Housing,
The Sun,
right at dawn on the spring equinox.
It's an equinox.
Your market.
Nobody would dispute that.
The ancient digit.
Well,
no,
I mean,
if you make a monument pointing perfectly joyous,
I've stood on the back of the Sphinx at dawn on the spring equinox,
and believe me,
I,
again,
I could show a picture.
It's headlines up perfectly with the rising sun,
but no,
I don't think anybody even crop is disputing that.
It's an exponential market.
Now,
here's the thing,
you're an ancient Egyptian.
You're building an equinox,
your marker in 2,500 BC.
Do you know what constellation is?
Housing the son in 2,500 BC.
I haven't run the little program,
and it's the constellation of Taurus.
So logically,
if you're creating an equinox,
IOM and the ancient Egyptians were not shy about making images of balls,
plenty of them.
If you're making an equinox your marker in 2,500 BC,
we should create it in the form of a bull,
not in the form of a lion.
You know,
that's the,
that's the puzzling issue.
And yet we do have a time when a lion constellation,
how's The sun at dawn on the spring equinox?
And that is the period of the younger dryas.
Okay.
I'd say that's a pretty big leap.
I know you'd say that.
And your colleagues will say that too.
There.
And then we have a gap of about five or 6,000 years where there's nothing.
There's no,
yeah.
Please do refer back to several articles that were published in the eighties and
nineties.
This one is from,
uh,
from nature early eighties,
late quarternary history of the Nile and what it's discussing is the evidence
that there was a major shift in the,
in the hydraulic regime of the Nile River.
Um,
it says between 20,000 and 12,000 years before present when timberline into
headwaters was lower vegetation cover more open than today.
The Nile was a highly seasonal,
braided river,
which brought mixed course and fine sediments down to Egypt and Sudan.
This cold,
dry interval had answered,
ended by 12,500 years before present when overflow from Lake Victoria and higher
rainfall in Ethiopia sent extraordinary floods down the Mayo main aisle.
And those floods had been documented to have been 120 feet above the modern
flood plain of denial.
Any civilization or whatever you want to call it,
living along denial river at that time would have had to abandon whatever they
were doing there.
In the industry regime,
there's intensified hydraulic regime and it says,
it goes on to say it marked a revolutionary change to continuous flow with a
superimposed flood peak.
So what happened is that there was a major environmental change that occurred
right there around 12,000 to 12,000,
500 years.
The dating could be adjusted somewhat,
uh,
since the early eighties.
But the point is made is that because of a major hydrological change,
major vegetational cover change,
major environmental change,
this would have caused also imposed changes upon whatever culture was existing
air or living near at the time.
Now,
what we have is in the aftermath of that event,
we have basically the emergence of desert,
which now would require serious adaptation.
Um,
it's very likely to that these events,
uh,
could have also decimated the population at the time,
leaving,
um,
basically no workforce.
And then over a period of two or three or 4,000 years,
you find that,
that there's enough of a recovery that these kinds of monumental structures can
be renewed.
Um,
but it's clear from this and a lot of other studies studies in the eastern
Mediterranean that there were SAP repel layers,
um,
which is caused,
which is basically material that has been washed in from the continental surface
that has not oxidized.
It is essentially become rotten and carried in organic material,
carried in off of the continents by this enhanced regime of,
of waterflow actually forcing so much water that there was a freshwater lid on
the eastern Mediterranean that,
uh,
caused a cessation in the,
um,
the,
the circulation between the upper waters and the lower waters reducing the
amount of oxygen brought down to the,
to the lower waters.
And so you had these layers of mud that formed on the bottom of the
Mediterranean that show this massive influx of fresh water flowing off of,
out of the Nile and off of the,
the Egyptian continent at the same time.
So clearly the evidence shows that there were major climatic changes that
occurred around this time.
It is not so speculative to to imagine that whoever,
whatever,
and we don't have to invoke any kind of a super advanced civilization,
but whatever cultures were there that were perhaps capable of carving blocks of
stone transporting blocks of stone as they were at go back,
Lee Tapi during this time range would have been that,
that their,
that their activity would have been interrupted to the extent that it might have
taken millennia to recover,
to get the,
get the labor force necessary to undertake major Mont monumental programs on the
Giza plateau.
So,
so I think that that the,
if we assume this gradual listic scenario,
yeah,
that's a fair question to ask were what happened in that interval.
But if there is a major climatic downturn and a major disruption of the settled
patterns of whatever culture was already there,
then you know,
now we might have an explanation why there would be a gap,
especially if these events caused a,
uh,
a bottleneck in the population of the area.
Of course this is all speculative,
but it is not speculative to say that there is multiple lines of evidence
suggesting these major even cataclysmic changes that engulfed that part of the
world during that era.
So that could,
that could provide an explanation of why there is a gap there.
Makes total sense.
Well it doesn't because does it not,
it only if you have to have this things in conjunction with 12,000 years ago in
the La Civilization.
If you just say that rain water erosion on the Sphinx,
uh,
it is not an explanation for the age and that the traditional accepted age is
what we think it is,
then there's no gap to fill.
Yeah.
So really all we're talking about is we have,
again,
lots of evidence here.
One anomaly here.
I really want the anomaly thing to stick.
So I got to explain the gap.
The gap is explained by environmental changes.
Lots of evidence other than a lot of assumptions.
It's,
and a lot of maybes.
It's only,
I mean,
actually,
can you cite me as single contemporary inscription from the date that the Sphinx
is supposed to have been made that refers to the swings?
I'm sorry.
Can you cite a single contemporary inscription to temporary from the
contemporary to the date that Egyptologist subscribe to the Sphinx?
In other words,
to the reign of [inaudible].
Can you cite me as single inscription that talks about the Sphinx being built?
This is,
I don't study this area.
I don't know.
Okay.
Well you can't because there is no such description.
Okay,
well,
so what one would have thought there would,
maybe it's a giant project.
There's 270 feet long.
It's 70 feet high.
It's carved out of solid rock.
Nothing.
No reference to how tall in the old kingdom.
You actually have to come down to the new kingdom to get references to the
Sphinx in inscriptions that,
but you've already said that the pyramids were built at the time we think they
were built,
not thousands of.
I would say that a great deal of work was done on the pyramids at the time of
2,500 pieces.
And I think the ground plan was laid out.
We have like the step pyramid,
which is crude or not as well designed as the other pyramids.
That's it.
That's a transitional stage at that time off and argued to be a transitional
stage.
Have you been to the step pyramid?
I'm sure.
Right?
And you've been to Giza though?
No,
I've never been to Giza.
Oh dear.
Well,
will they do make a very different impact?
I mean,
I've climbed the Great Pyramid five times.
you're dealing with something orders of magnitude different in terms of what's
required.
I mean this thing weighs 6 million,
but it's 481 feet high.
It consists of two and a half million individual blocks of stone.
It's aligned to true north within three 60th of a single degree.
I mean,
to compare that to [inaudible],
uh,
is really not a valid comparison at all.
What's more interesting to me is the radical decline that takes place in pyramid
building skills.
In the fifth and sixth dynasty,
go to Ou Nassco to pepe,
go to teddy at Sakara.
These are a shambles.
You can hardly even recognize them as a pyramid.
What happened to all that knowledge that's invested in the Great Pyramid?
Why does Egypt to devolve so rapidly?
Uh,
how do we explain this pristine,
amazing work that's done on the Great Pyramid?
Unless there's a legacy of knowledge being attached to it.
Okay,
so every archeologist,
Egypt,
Egyptian archeologist and Egyptian,
I'll knows everything you just said they did and they don't accept any of your
arguments.
Why not?
That's why I needed,
because somebody's got to counter this is it just that they're closed minded and
they follow a,
as I hear of us and they never think for themselves.
You want to see a coroner's mind?
I'll play or one and a half minute video of Zaria wash refusing to debate with
me.
But all of them,
every one of the Egyptologist and archaeologist over the last two centuries and
so on,
they know they're all dogmatically close minded.
And they can't see the arguments declares you or is it,
they're not convinced by your argument.
They're not convinced by my argument.
They genuinely an absolutely believe that their argument is right.
The notion that I'm proposing is apparently so preposterous to them that it
isn't even worthy of consideration,
but it is worthy of insults and attacks on me,
on my integrity,
on my decency as a human being on my honesty.
All of those things get attacked,
you know,
because main street and that's fine.
I'm ready for that.
And that,
by the way,
I know that archaeologists,
academics constantly attack each other all the time.
I used to take this stuff personally,
but then I just,
when I see what they do to each other,
the ravaging attack dogs,
I let loose on,
on any new idea.
I sometimes wish scientists would,
would actually look for what's good in a new idea rather than what's bad.
But I get why they do it for what's bad.
But in other words,
a grant that some young graduate student working in that area could make a name
for himself by overturning,
uh,
you know,
my son was a young graduate student at the University of Cardiff studying
Egyptology.
He got marked down in his degree because he proposed the possibility that the
pyramids and the Sphinx might be or might have older origins.
Uh,
he was impressed by my work.
It did him a lot of harm in his degree.
And,
and if all of this was true,
uh,
that event,
you organize it by point by point,
which is if you go against the mainstream view,
your career does not progress as an egyptologist.
I disagree.
I mean,
how many an example,
how is it that we know anything that we know about Egypt,
for example,
from Egypt tology of somebody who's gone against the mainstream view and being
lauded for,
so doing well,
look,
we don't believe everything about it that we believe two centuries ago say
Napoleon's time.
Right?
How did all that knowledge come about?
How did all the change and that science technology begins with Sham polyon and
the deciphering of the Rosetta stone.
Right.
All right.
How was he able to do that against the mainstream?
There was no main stream.
All right.
So,
but he was a client that was nice.
The mainstream has taken time to form and it's a very solid now.
I mean,
just all sing from the same hymnbook you'll find very little disagreement every
field.
But somehow or another Einstein managed to,
to make an impact because he turned out to be right.
Well,
I'm no Einstein,
and I don't know if I'm right,
but I'm going to continue to oppose that main street if somebody has to us,
if that's a valid comparison.
Einstein and archeology take Paleo anthropology.
I mean,
it's a completely different field now than a century ago.
How did that happen?
If no one ever accepts new ideas?
They do.
It happens all the time.
Okay.